- [Voiceover] So we've been
talking about the progress
of the American Civil War
which started in early 1861
after the 11 states of the
South, which were slave states,
seceded from the Union
and tried to establish
an independent nation
known as the Confederate
States of America.
And in the first years of the Civil War
things went relatively well for the South.
They defeated the North
at the Battle of Bull Run
which was a great surprise to many people
because they thought
that this was going to be
a pretty short war, that the
South would be quickly defeated
and scared away into
returning to the Union.
But the South had many advantages
including very good leadership
in the person of Robert E. Lee
and also kind of a home
court advantage at large
since the vast majority of the
war was fought in the South.
So in this early stage the
Confederacy does quite well
until we get to Antietam.
And Antietam was this first
foray by Robert E. Lee
in trying to attack the states
of the North in Maryland.
And after the Battle of Antietam
which was the bloodiest
day in U.S. history,
more than 4,000 Americans
died on that day,
the South was defeated.
And that was a major
turning point in the war
as we've talked about in previous videos
in that it led to the
Emancipation Proclamation
and was kind of the moment at
which the nations of Europe
cease to consider intervening
on the side of the South.
So in the next few videos
I want to talk about the
later stages of the Civil War.
So we get into 1863 and the
South is doing relatively well
here in Virginia, wins the
Battle of Chancellorsville
and now, nearly a year after Antietam
in June and July of 1863,
Robert E. Lee decides that
he is going to try again
to invade the North.
Now he's several reasons for doing this.
One, is that the war has been taking place
largely in the South
so it's summer, people are
trying to harvest their crops
and Lee wants to give the South a break
so he wants to take the attention away
from this area in Virginia
where lots of fighting has happened
and he wants to take the
war up into the North.
And if the North is distracted
by having to defend its own territory
then it can't go on the
offensive elsewhere as easily.
So Lee's plan is to take
the war to the North
and Lee has another reason in his sleeve
which is that he is really hoping
that in the Election of 1864
which is coming up not too long
after this period in
mid-1863, many people believe
that Lincoln is going to
be kicked out of office.
Now remember, that not a
single American President
has been elected to a second term
or reelected since Andrew Jackson in 1832.
So there's been a 30 year
drought of two term presidents.
So Robert E. Lee has good reason to expect
why Lincoln might not be reelected in 1864
and he thinks that maybe
one of Lincoln's competitors
in the Democratic Party,
which will turn out to be
one of his own former
generals, George B. McClellan
will actually want to end the war
and make peace with the South.
So there's kind of a
morale aspect to this.
You can see that many of the
things done in the Civil War
and especially as we get
into the later stages
are designed at making
one side or the other
tired of being at war.
Now you may wonder why
I'm spending so much time
talking about battles because
most American History courses
do not emphasize military
history whatsoever.
But I think it's important
to keep in mind in this war
and in some earlier wars
like the American Revolution
the battles really
determine the policy, right,
because you can't make
a decree like the way
that Abraham Lincoln decreed
the Emancipation Proclamation
if you don't have the force
of military power behind you.
So winning battles, winning the
war, those kind of victories
give politicians the
popular mandate they need
to get things done.
So that's why I think that
it's important to talk,
at least a little bit, about
the battles of the Civil War.
Now obviously, Bull Run,
Antietam, Gettysburg,
and Appomattox were not the
only battles of the Civil War,
there were hundreds of
battles of the Civil War
but I've chosen these as
particular turning points
just to kind of give you
a very brief overview
of the way that military victories
and defeats were trending.
Because along with
those military victories
and defeats went the
policy of the United States
and the policy of the South.
And if you're interested in the Civil War
it's one of the most written about topics
in American history and there
are many wonderful books
that will go into great
detail about the politics,
society, and military
history of the Civil War,
and lots of great television
shows, and miniseries
that I definitely suggest
that you check out.
All right, well, with that said
let's talk about Gettysburg.
So Lee has brought his
forces into the North
and, again, he's interested in
kind of distracting the North
from attacking in the South
by bringing the war to them.
He's hoping to prolong the war
so that perhaps another
administration that's more favorable
to allowing the South to go peacefully
might be in office in the North.
And the other thing that
he's looking for is supplies
so once again the vast
majority of the Civil War
has been fought in the South
and it's been fought here
in this sort of Shenandoah
Valley, Tidewater region
of Virginia which is really
the breadbasket of the South.
So when men are out fighting battles
and when battles are
being fought on fields
instead of crops being grown on them,
there's going to be a serious
dearth of food in the South.
You know I once heard it said
that the most salient political
fact of the 20th century
was that the Americans speak English
which means that the United States
repeatedly allied with
Britain in 20th century wars.
But if I had to choose
the most salient fact
of the American Civil War it might be that
you can't eat cotton.
You know the South went to war
to protect its system of labor
so that it could continue
to produce these cash crops
like cotton or tobacco.
And cash crops they may be
which means that you
can sell them for money
but you can't eat cotton or tobacco.
And when it comes down to it
being able to feed your troops
and feed your populace
is something that's
going to really help you
when it comes to winning a war.
So Lee is taking his
troops up into the North
and he takes them into
Southern Pennsylvania
which is very lovely farmland.
It's a very beautiful place
if you've never been there,
I absolutely recommend you take a look,
go to Gettysburg it's a very
well preserved battlefield.
And as Lee goes through
Southern Pennsylvania
his troops are taking
horses, and grain supplies,
and all sorts of things that
the army needs to survive
which are in short supply in Virginia.
So this is like a run to the store for Lee
going through Southern Pennsylvania.
On the Northern side, General George Meade
has been trying to catch
up with Lee and cut him off
from his invasion of the North.
President Abraham Lincoln
asks for many volunteers
to try to stave off the
invasion of the North by Lee
and they end up meeting at Gettysburg.
And Gettysburg is just a small farm town
in Southern Pennsylvania,
it's just where these
two troops happen to meet
as Lee was on his way
to the capital of Pennsylvania, Harrisburg
and Lee's forces and Meade's
forces meet on July 1st, 1863.
Now the Battle of Gettysburg
goes on for three days
so there's July 1st,
July 2nd, and July 3rd.
And the first day goes relatively
well for the Confederates,
they break some of the Union
lines around the edges.
The second day is kind of a stalemate
where Northern forces and Southern forces,
they sustain a lot of losses
but don't make any real
headway toward victory.
And then the third day, Lee
decides that he is going to try
to break the center of the Union forces
which means that he is going
to try to hit the Union line,
and remember this is in
the era of military history
where people are still
kind of fighting in lines,
right through the center, and win the day.
Unfortunately for him
that is not what happens
so he tries all day to
break the Union lines.
There's a very famous sort of last hurrah
for the Southern forces in
this called Pickett's Charge
when General George Pickett's
units charge up this hill
at Cemetery Ridge trying to break the line
and they sustain over 50% casualties
so it's kind of a bloodbath
for Pickett's unit.
And after Pickett's
Charge does not succeed
the Union forces have officially won
the Battle of Gettysburg and Lee realizes
that there's no way that
he's going to be able
to make anything out of
his invasion of the North
and so he turns around and
starts heading back to the South.
Now what's important about Gettysburg
is that this was what many
have called the High Water Mark
of the Confederacy.
And by that they mean
this is as far as the
Confederacy ever managed
to get into the Northern
part of the United States.
This is a second attempt at an
invasion by Lee and it failed
and many people see this as a
really important turning point
in the Civil War on July 4th.
And imagine the good news of
receiving word that your troops
had triumphed on July
4th, Independence Day.
President Lincoln and the United States
get another really good piece of news
which is that Ulysses S. Grant
who will be the future
commander of U.S. forces
has succeeded in his siege of Vicksburg
which is a town on the Mississippi River.
And when he takes the town
on the Mississippi River
Grant has complete
control of the Mississippi
which is sort of the
major highway in the West.
So July 3rd and July
4th are really good days
for the United States and
this is kind of the moment
when it becomes clear that victory
is going to be outside the
reach of the Confederacy.
And with an unsuccessful
invasion of the North
and the loss of the
control of the Mississippi,
the South's time is kind
of coming to an end.
The other important thing
about the Battle of Gettysburg
is that it is a tremendously
destructive battle,
about 50,000 casualties
took place at Gettysburg
which makes it the single bloodiest battle
in American history which is different
from the single bloodiest
day which was at Antietam
because it took place over three days.
And this is not 50,000 people
dying, just 50,000 casualties
which means either deaths or injuries,
those are men who can no
longer fight on both sides.
So the tremendous loss
of life at Gettysburg
is going to lead to the foundation
of a cemetery at Gettysburg
to bury these military dead.
And it's going to be in November of 1863,
just a couple of months after
the Battle of Gettysburg,
that Abraham Lincoln will visit
the cemetery at Gettysburg
and deliver the Gettysburg Address,
one of the most famous orations
in all of American history
and we'll get to that in the next video.